welcome to this video Isis guys still
not bad can message the ISIS c4 before
on and on and still have to play against
a bloody cheater here okay me maybe it's
not using it this time I have won two
games against him somehow so on him so
here with g3
and see what happens
very normal
theoretical line normally coming away
from the nihms oh god from this water
but I didn't if you like him um like Ben
Oni yeah it's the main line of that
opening I looked at this like two or
three years ago when my project was
starting checking if this is something
that can be recommended for black it is
not bad at all it's them I said as songs
something like the main line but it has
one drawback it's sometimes a bit a bit
dry and difficult to do something with
will be 8 maybe 94 and she was the
knight on c5 a possible Queen c2 okay
let's go back him
okay so 95 is not good and I think I
should make sure that night before is
not coming it's got a pretty active
position and you never know he might
might use an engine on a 24 core
computer so 95 if I go Knight g5 there
what is he doing
just taking place you fire probably
typically cold-blooded style Bishop g5
has probably f6 coming ship age 3 and
interesting
let's try I mean as I said this is a
cheetah
and sorry don't care much Jim
maybe c5 is a move here
see five could be interesting hmm yeah
so nineteen I can taking what this
should takes Knight takes rook takes
Queen Ephraim maybe this is really
somewhat maybe this is working somehow
for me uh-huh this one
96,000 26
so that's useless no way I can take
stinks should be six am still in a pin
so 96 is not not going to work now I
have to go back with the bishop them
maybe all the way I don't see don't see
a good square and now probably f5 95
Bishop c5 probably threatening Bishop f2
hmm
Bishop c5 and I really don't have a good
move there 93 is also a problem let's
say Queen 80 to 93 yeah straightening
bishop f2 mmm I don't have any sort of
move Queen d2 it's probably Knight c3
good work okay just kicks it back
so now one is going to take it to take
f3 so probably losing the stuff between
c-3po f2 okay
but you can go Bishop e2 probably can
you do that 94 maybe I can go 94 check
check uh-huh yeah of course yeah you can
take f1 and you know if he wants to he
can play perfectly you know
check yeah I mean I have messaged the
people they had as you see to bend this
guy but it sometimes takes and sometimes
takes a long and since the last one I'm
sure is still the same session since I
complained so it's not like they don't
do anything for one week yeah I can't
let's resign this game white resides I
can again shake some engine correlation
here so six Quincy to seven and that's
all computer but it's also rather
normal-looking Queen b6 before we see
aids or stock fish f6 of course I should
buy three c5 best move also engine takes
Quincy six
stock fish f5 mc5 aged 693 check check
check
it's 100% stock fish 5 100% yeah it's
100% I mean in this particular case I
think the Moose were kind of I mean I
mostly called out the move so it wasn't
so difficult but still yeah they I
really hope they had to bend this guy
what exactly went wrong there however I
mean the thing is that I really don't
pay any close attention ever playing as
she does because it's just entirely
pointless but still what exactly was was
wrong here and probably Bishop g5 yeah
this ideas its kind of interesting but
against the computer it's it's totally
pointless
it finds c5 and like is better so 95 I
was thinking about this idea but again
it can probably really take and maybe go
see five likes activity is pretty good
him the engine wants to play night see 5
p.m. just stopping any c5 business and
queen here now but that seems ok for
black really yeah as I said I don't
really know that line to well maybe my
response on loopy aid is already not not
so precise this is a very yeah I don't
know it's a very delicate position where
where some some little missteps can be
can mean that white gives away any
chance of an advantage and we saw that I
wasn't trouble really quickly now anyway
thanks for watching